hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to pass part out no no
that's not how you pronounce it but
being an ignorant American that's the
best as I can do and if you've seen my
markiplier makes art video you know I
don't do a French accent very well so
I'm gonna just continue this without
offending as many people as possible and
then I'm gonna offend people with my art
instead which is a more profitable
measure because that's what I'm
hopefully gonna be doing here act one
new beginnings ah what a lovely place in
the back alley of party that wasn't even
close again thought I should warn myself
not to try a French accent
but the easel to start painting ah of
course oh I wonder how my art is going
to be well first let's just wash this at
home Wow now let me give it something
that's gonna actually represent my soul
here
[Music]
okay all right I think we're forming
something good here ah a thing of beauty
I call this red man in the eye I think
it's beautiful
speaks to my soul right now let's place
out right there all right red man in the
eye hey anybody want to buy red man in
the eye red man
yeah hey excuse me you as the baguettes
get the [ __ ] over here and buy my art
hey [ __ ] where are you even going
were you standing in the corner over
there was even the point of this
adventure
you gonna buy my art or what Oh ha ha
orange in the light
yeah hey I'll take it
oh ho 13 euros or 19 euros red oh I
better start painting these guys are
going like hotcakes black it out again
Wow
ah yeah okay all right I think I like it
I like where this isn't going I can
really feel this one I really see how
this one's taking shape yeah happy
little accidents okay all right this
one's called red man getting closer red
man getting closer oh yeah
well this is our bye now Oh keep track
of my cash flow I don't know what do I
need to spend so much money on baguettes
oh dude oh you're too dull with your
spiky hair and your args shirt and your
rain boots it's not even raining you
stupid idiot we did big ol hoop earrings
boy a [ __ ] loser with your chains are
you got a wallet chain why don't you go
buy my [ __ ] okay ah cool like it so far
like it - doll - doll are you kidding me
oh this is perfection right here this is
perfection you see what I'm going for
here everybody trying to speak to the
inner workings of my soul whoo fresh
like a morning baguette ate it hates
well baguette mans my best customer here
self red man sees you red man getting
closer sulfur nine dollars that guy is
gonna be [ __ ] possessed by the end of
his game that guy doesn't even know
what's about to happen to him uh I'm
gonna keep painting like an [ __ ]
oh thanks Monsieur this tingles my
facial hair as it should it should
tingle it with a knife because it's
murderous eye let's paint another one
before that guy gets out of here yeah
wait hang on
no don't go don't go man I'll call this
red thumb red thumb dot dot or who knows
what could it be
I don't know it's a painting it's up
there now so you do whatever you got
going on there
haha original white that's a horrible
all right you can have it you have the
the red man's dick Oh Batman is just the
art CONUS wha all right fine let me do
work with some different colors here
uh-huh yeah oh yeah this is a good one
oh that's good Monsieur
oh wow ah back yet Bonjour Eiffel Tower
Chanel
there we go there we go that looks good
gonna call that one uh not so starring
night starring mr. Redmayne man I'm
painting these faster than they are they
they're selling faster than I can paint
them it's fairly well made oh thank you
George I will take that I think that as
a compliment you are so nice not so
sorry night oh that's so sweet actually
I didn't put any effort into that one
but still okay I got this one huh okay
it's uh it's red man go to bed
here we go oh there we go
he's so cute he's tucked in the bed and
his billows red man goes night-night
there we go oh oh go look at it you know
you want it
twenty let's get some other colors in
here
Swamp Bay women Wow puddin bah
where's this taking me oh I don't know
but the creative expression is flowing
through me oh I feel so fulfilled
oh there's red man you're looking so
good red man no look so good all right
there we go go get that one you know you
want it you know you want it do doll
[ __ ] you I want to see more focus on the
craft well I want to see more focus on
the [ __ ] you that's what I want to see
eat a dick
there we go how's that for craft how's
that for craft you got plenty pretty
flower go plenty plenty pretty flower
there you go
there's craft for you and I must start
going abstract because this obviously
ain't working for me
there we go it's done I call it eraser
from school memories of my elementary
array erasure from school memories lost
mmm better start buying my art or else
someone started stabbing somebody okay
there we go
it's done I love where's the energy made
it's bland your bland intersecting
moments of life there we go all right
I'm gonna really put my effort into this
one there we go I called this one blood
on a rainy day cuz I got nothing else to
call it what else would i ah thank you
thank you
colors too crazy for you colors too
crazy colors it's one if you don't count
white all right how about this I'm gonna
make I know what I'm gonna do I know
what I must do to truly channel the
greatest art excellent alright I call
this one the Eiffel Tower at nights no
Eiffel Tower at sunrise I don't think I
even spelled Eiffel correctly put in
some effort will you I put in so much
effort yeah I'm trying to be some sort
of minimalist what else would I be
excuse me I gotta get red man in a
butthole
there you go red man in a butthole whoa
awesome made no better color combination
than pink and brown if you ask me uh-huh
okay I like this one Oh mix my facial
hair tingle does it oh you get that one
there we go
done done pink hair don't care
fine I'll get rid of that one how do I
throw one away can I just burn one
I don't think I'm gonna make it here uh
I'm trying my best
I'm trying my ding-dong damn best I get
the nose her nipples are way up there
there we go got it nailed it to see
perky look up that one hurt whoa Gerard
isn't based on skill I love it mate
you like perky Maggie oh hell yeah yeah
you do I'm gonna go for like uh like the
Banksy style message here it's all about
capitalism man it's both about the
capitalism destroying the integrity of
art capitalism kappa will lost capital
assam d.c story integrity of art that's
what that one called that one called
capitalism i don't know what you want
there we go got it nailed it whoa not
shoddy at all hey I think I found it
Zelda got it nailed it all right how
about this one that was pretty cool
I'm gonna call that one fourth of July
hmm I've unlocked a new tool the new
tool that's awesome I thought I was
gonna be dying
whoo thank you heck oh yeah all right I
know what I found my art style I've
found my art cell Lovejoy
fine whatever I'll throw it away people
don't like that one people don't like my
Banksy oh thank you
that's good whatever I love capitalism
then I love capitalism destroying the
integrity of my I art what is this Oh
spray well I want a nice this is doing
nothing ah wonderful here we go
I know what I'm gonna do nailing it got
it nailed it got it great got it great
nailed it
six of July no first [ __ ] disease
arm actually this taking a while to get
them through that's not bad that's
soothing it's relaxing even whoo thank
you it's going well for me
seventh
I think this one's gonna come together
real good here I call this one you see
what you wanna see yeah whoa
59 oh thank you for that I appreciate it
oh man I'm not gonna be starving for
long baguettes for me all day and all
night I'm done okay I call this one the
sponge
screams not the sponge screams the
sponge screams shut up not meant for you
I call that one it goes tug whoo
expression does not require skill thank
you I'll take that as a compliment I
think 50 yeah I don't know I just keep
drawing circles like this my only go-to
thing it's not even a trick I was about
to say it's a trick this is my one trick
I go in a lot of circles and scribble a
lot my draw won't do it in there yes
good that's a good one I'm a called
Allan - good yeah scoot I'm gonna make a
comic here done got bored half way
through I'm gonna call it that one got
bored halfway through whoa this artists
understands me I do I do understand you
I really really do they like my circles
I'm pretty sure it's my circles that
they really like skillful crap I finally
impress Steve skillful craft Wow okay
right here we go this might be my
masterpiece windows alternate logos
that's good stick whoo 50 not bad there
we go got it oh I feel like a sim who
feel like a sim you know a sin that's
just like slowly building up their art
skill by painting a bajillion paintings
and none of them are good am i painting
without passion what do you mean without
passion I've got I've got oodles of
fashion it looks like Sesame Street I
somehow drew a Sesame Street sign
somehow I did that I don't know how I
did it but I'm gonna call that one
passion what happens if I don't accept
their offer
does it create like a bidding war or
something this might be my greatest work
yet this might be my ultimate
masterpiece I'm gonna call this one my
masterpiece and with that I think I'm
gonna stand right here next to it as
they judge it harshly and I'm not gonna
accept any offers on it because I don't
need your charity good no I don't want
it I want your money
you think I do this for money huh no
right here
Oh ninety-four no I don't think so I
don't do this for money
look I do this for the expression of the
art not the expression of my wallet you
understand what I'm saying here do you
even understand something you do I don't
think you do 94 I'll take it that's a
new record so not bad I guess I don't
know why I took so long on this one but
that is it this is my new masterpiece it
is gorgeous it is frickin gorgeous whoo
112 well the offer will be back if I
don't take it so there we go
I don't know what it is but I think it's
two dudes fighting on a cross bridge do
dudes fight and war skillful crafts oh
wait all right I'll take it off shut up
at least I'm selling them at least Tom's
cell and um their I now have a stripe of
every color in who know their craft okay
you go for that now I've got a stripe of
every color in this [ __ ] every single
color is in that one what hipster shops
we've decided that you're becoming too
popular expect no more money from us
what I expect nothing I don't even know
what that means what do you mean you're
expecting what does that mean what does
that mean I don't know what that means
so [ __ ] you guys
I don't need you hey past part out sway
event reverberating and new ideas to
become a hot topic
ah I'm getting popular there we go
alright I call this one beep boop borp
I'm a robo beat move for I'm a robo
alright well let's take a game or money
from the hipster chef so I got to keep
going in what I got - this is so weird
this is oddly fun like this game is just
satisfying I mean I know that my art is
[ __ ] my quote unquote hard but yeah
just having fun whoa brilliant May 117
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah give me that money
I'm a sellout I ain't ashamed just easy
for the cash
oh yeah you know it of course I am what
else would I be doing this [ __ ] there we
go static ghost maybe static ghost
yes something along those lines now how
should I ruin this one you know what
it's fine whatever they think without
passion that alien is screaming all
right
zebra of passion hmm
[Music]
there we go I don't know what I'm gonna
call this one okay I'm a Colin do-over
don't know why people don't like my
paintings banned people those just don't
understand my art made a painting mate
you did but you didn't make art oh [ __ ]
you whoa thank you
[Music]
there we go all right I think I'm gonna
end it on that one
whatever one this one is I'm I was like
that end that is the end of all things
and with that I think I'm done with this
game I've been playing this for the
better part of an hour just kind of like
fiddling with paintings it's weird
everything I did that uh the art video
I'll put a link in the description if
you want to see it uh but emphasized
that art video was like yeah that's kind
of cool just to be able to create
[ __ ] and whatever it is is what it
is so with this stuff it's like I got no
stakes in it Oh provoking and shocking I
freaking love it well that's good I'm a
pass I like that one I'm gonna keep that
bear see if anybody else likes it I
don't know if anybody wheels will colors
too crazy for me whatever it is but this
is one not bad for a little indie game I
don't know how they judge these
paintings but obviously uh probably by
artistic merit and I don't have any of
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down my my little pieces of art here
down in the comments below and thanks
again now as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]